everyone has bad dreams whether they're
about unconscious memories showing up to
school in your underwear or a man in a
stripy sweater with a spiky glove and a
serious moisturizing problem nightmares
are never far from us a common
occurrence as part of the human
experience and they can happen to anyone
of course working for the scp foundation
means being faced with actual nightmares
not only in the middle of the night but
on a day-to-day basis giant unkillable
lizards with pure hatred for humanity
ancient eldritch beings with enough
cosmic power to wipe out entire
dimensions and a species of buses with
gigantic insect legs that feed on human
beings needless to say the researchers
and operatives that find themselves
employed by the scp foundation come face
to face with some pretty horrific
creatures enough to give anyone
sleepless nights this naturally begs the
question what could possibly scare the
workers of the scp foundation what could
the foundation possibly have nightmares
about well they don't really have a name
for him just a designation
scp-990 multiple members of foundation
staff have all made reports of
witnessing the same entity after all
when you deal with dangerous cognito
hazards for a living it's worth taking
every unusual occurrence seriously
instead of just relying on the old it's
just a dream excuse anyone from doctors
and research personnel to mobile task
force operatives and those working as
anomaly guarding security every person
working for the foundation is at risk of
an unwanted encounter with scp-990
the reports are all consistent they all
describe a man seemingly a human being
this figure always seems to appear
dressed in a business suit but not like
you might see a modern ceo or a wall
street stockbroker wearing instead
scp-990 sense of fashion seems to be at
least a few decades out and he seems to
favor wearing clothing more in line with
the style of the cold war era wait that
can't be it right the big bad boogeyman
that terrorizes the dreams of the scp
foundation staff is just a man in a suit
what is he an irs agent well while
scp-990 might not be all that scary to
look at when compared to other
frightening anomalies like the haunting
beaked visage of the plague doctor or
the unknowable horror that is scp-096
it's not the way he looks that's
terrifying it is the ominous warnings
that he carries with him what is
interesting is that while most dreams
are usually our brain's way of
processing our memories or real-world
experiences and anxieties
scp-990 seems to have no recorded
existence beyond what has been reported
by staff he seems to exclusively exist
within the dreams of foundation
personnel with absolutely none of these
people having witnessed or encountered
the suit wearing man in the real world
if there is somewhere out there among
the 7 billion people on planet earth a
man who resembles scp-990 then the
foundation has been unsuccessful in
tracking him down what's more is that
there has never been a single report
from outside of the foundation not one
civilian or even any member of another
group of interest that anyone else has
ever had a dream involving scp-990
for years now he's been cropping up
exclusively in the nightmares of
foundation personnel but was first
discovered a number of years ago after
several agents began to discuss the fact
that they all had experienced similar
dreams all revolving around a mysterious
man in a cold war-era business suit but
then he finally became known to the
higher-ups at the foundation after one
peculiar incident an agent had failed to
report to his assigned post at the right
time and from that moment on things
would never be the same again
after scouring the foundation facility
for this missing agent when fellow
members of personnel found him he was
fast asleep in his quarters doesn't seem
too unusual right after all working at
the scp foundation has got to be pretty
hard going with some horrendous overtime
hours so maybe the agent just needed to
catch up on some sleep by taking a quick
nap before the start of his shift then
again 18 whole hours is one hell of a
long nap that's right the man had been
unconscious for 18 hours when they found
him fellow foundation staff were unable
to awaken the sleeping agent his body
having entered some form of short-term
coma unsure if he would ever awake again
medical personnel had the agent move to
the sickbay on-site where he was placed
under surveillance and continued his
long sleep after almost two whole days
and an uninterrupted 40-hour period of
sustained sleep the agent finally awoke
he was agitated erratic clearly
something had rattled him pretty
severely the agent dashed out of his bed
in the medical bay and began frantically
running through the corridors of the
foundation facility screaming and
babbling about the impending end of the
entire world eventually medics were able
to restrain the man injecting him with
powerful sedatives to relax him long
enough for them to secure him yet
somehow the agent's bodily functions
remained in a heightened state even
after he was sedated his heart was
beating at a dangerously accelerated
rate and his blood pressure was spiking
to quite an alarming degree now we may
not be medical experts but we can
guarantee that high blood pressure and
an elevated heart rate are rarely ever
good signs then again neither is being
asleep and unable to wake for 40 solid
hours as you may have already guessed
when he finally calmed down the agent
described a dream that revolved around a
man dressed in a business suit that
seemed to match the styles of the cold
war era in other words scp-999
but you see it's not like the mysterious
man trapped the agent in this 40-hour
dream just to torture him there was no
pulling the agent through the center of
his mattress causing a volcanic eruption
of blood to splatter up to the ceiling
scp-990 didn't wrap any bed sheets
around the agent's neck or slash at him
using a glove with a blade at the end of
each finger instead all scp-990 did
during the course of the agent's dream
was deliver a message well actually it
was more of a warning than anything else
after he had awoken and calmed down from
his prior outburst the agent was being
evaluated by a foundation doctor during
this evaluation the agent was able to
describe in the most acute precise
detail imaginable a chilling sequence of
events something that was so accurate
that it could only have been true
instead of just an inconsequential dream
or a fabricated made-up story the agent
was describing exactly how the world was
going to end not a single detail was
omitted the exact times and dates the
tipping of every domino on the
geopolitical landscape that would
ultimately lead to annihilation scp-999
had appeared in the agent's dream to
describe exactly how at some point in
time a series of events would culminate
in multiple tactical nuclear warheads
being launched these deadly weapons of
mass destruction would head straight for
targets in central europe and eastern
asia seeming to imply that the missiles
were being launched by the united states
of america the resulting devastation of
the nuclear payload would wipe out
almost the entirety of the human race
exterminating around 98 of the planet's
population society would collapse on a
global scale and the world would be
rendered a barren inhospitable wasteland
ravaged by radioactive fallout every
detail of this impending apocalypse was
relayed to the agent by scp-990
including exactly who and what would
trigger the initial chain of events
destined to end in total destruction of
earth deciding to take the mysterious
suited man's message seriously the scp
foundation dispatched one of its elite
mobile task forces to eliminate that
initial threat removing the thing that
would topple the first domino while the
crisis was averted and the world saved
the agent who first reported his
encounter with scp-990 died suffering
symptoms resembling severe shock of
course just because you managed to stop
one approaching apocalypse doesn't mean
that there won't be others in fact when
you think about it that's the scariest
thing about scp-990
it's not that he appears in foundation
personnel's dreams it's that his work is
never done he always brings with him a
new warning of a new disaster on the
horizon if anything the ripples caused
by preventing one of these crises only
create another to deal with since this
initial incident now designated as event
990-07
scp-990 has made a number of similarly
ominous warnings through the nightmares
of other members of the scp foundation
any one of this business suit wearing
omen's warnings come with almost 100
certainty rate he can foresee the future
without any margin of error successfully
predicting the exact dates times and
causes of the deaths of multiple doctors
working for the foundation even the
destruction of a noted facility known as
watch station epsilon 38 was foretold by
an appearance of scp-990
of course theories about who or what
exactly this man is are common but with
no clear definite answer to speak of it
is currently up in the air if this
entity is some sort of guardian angel
helping the scp foundation protect
humanity from their own downfall and
guiding us all to safety or he could be
a visitor from an infinite number of
potential futures projecting himself
back in time to avert whatever course of
action led to the end of the world the
staff at the scp foundation are
encouraged to come forward if they ever
have a nocturnal encounter with scp-990
with one doctor even believing that the
man has a physical body somewhere out
there in the real world during one dream
with scp-990 in it a foundation doctor
was able to conduct a complete interview
with the man now we all know that it can
be pretty tricky to recall the details
of a dream after waking up but this
particular doctor claimed to have an
almost impeccable memory it is unclear
how exactly this doctor was able to
converse so clearly with scp-990 but
with so many people working for the
foundation perhaps it was only a matter
of time before the man in the suit found
one capable of lucid dreaming after
commencement of this dream interview
when asked for his name scp-990
responded with tony as if he pulled the
name from thin air when the doctor asked
if this was his real name
scp-990 claimed that a person should
have the right to be called whatever
they wish to be called before changing
his mind and asking to be called richard
instead the doctor pressed on asking the
man why he had been delivering threats
to foundation personnel through their
dreams
scp-990 seemed confused by this then the
doctor rebutted by accusing the
dreamwalker of murdering the agent the
one who had first reported his encounter
with scp-990
hearing this the entity explained that
the foundation had the wrong impression
of him claiming that he wasn't the bad
guy upon mention of a bad guy being
involved the doctor's next course of
action was naturally to ask who this
might be and then
scp-990 said something even stranger it
was the designation of another scp but
not one that the foundation had ever
encountered before there didn't even
exist any anomaly under the number that
the mysterious dream man had given there
is no scp with that designation and
there won't be for some time the doctor
argued growing ever more confused and
agitated well of course not scp 990
replied she hasn't even been born yet
much less classified by your foundation
when asked if this was another
prediction of an impending disaster yet
another threat that could end the entire
world
scp-990 simply told the doctor this is
your wake-up call since then no one is
certain who or what this future anomaly
could be whether she has since been
contained by the foundation or if that
is still yet to come the sad part about
our dreams is that they only ever really
offer us a look backwards memories and
experiences all warped in our sleeping
brains none of us can look forward
nobody knows exactly what the future
holds well none of us accept
scp-990 that is it has been a long time
since the foundation designated scp-990
if that prophesized nightmare of an scp
has been born and designated since then
what do you think she is let us know
down in the comments now go check out
scp-3017 the most dangerous person alive
and scp-1440 the old man that kills all
living things he touches for more eerie
humanoid as cps